hi my name is George Woodrow and I'm
giving a talk on hermeneutics and
Wolfram language
this is a fourth talk I've given it the
wulfing conference in each of the others
I've emphasized that my success as a
designer / programmer it's been greatly
aided by my experiences in the arts and
humanities
this talk is definitely a work in
progress it is part of a larger project
to make a rigorous connection between
metaphor is used in the arts and
humanities and model as it used in
mathematics it is my belief that
education has become too siloed too
specialized CP snows concept of two
worlds if anything understates the
problem in the not-too-distant past
philosophies science and maths were not
separated now it seems as though the
humanities and Sciences are armed camps
I think that the sciences need
philosophy today more than ever the talk
is structured around the four-step
process
found on the computer-based mass website
and this is somewhat arbitrary but it
provides a familiar handle for the
problem whoops there we go hora notice
is the theory of interpretation is the
theory that everything is a matter of
interpretation Caputo goes on to say
that there are facts of course but
there's no such thing as a brawl fact is
it this concept even reasonable recent
discoveries and neuroscience can set
shed some light on the matter it is
pretty clear that what we perceive as
naive reality is in fact a construct
built from the mind using signals sent
by the eyes ears and other sense organs
for example we have no sensation at all
the rapid eye movements as rapid move as
the eye makes is to scan the scene only
resulting construct visual illusions
show how the mind can be tricked when
reality is not what is expected further
shot studies have shown that there's
very little difference between normal
perception and hallucination in the case
of normal perception
the brain verifies this construct with
the outside world and in the case of
hallucination it does not of course this
mechanism has evolved over millions of
years for a survival value so most of
the time the construct has a close
correspondence with the real world some
parts of our perception mechanism are
influenced by culture we see artifacts
of cultural transition such as a rise of
geometric perspective invented by
artists before mathematicians in the
change in art during the Renaissance
what we have in fact is a need to
re-examine some of our basic assumptions
about how we experience the world our
mind is not a blank slate at birth our
eyes are not cameras that provide a
faithful recording of whatever we are
looking at in our everyday interactions
we are a living interpretation where
hermeneutics and its techniques such as
deconstruction it's aimed at is a way to
examine the tendency to miss identify
our constructions for reality this
tendency goes by many different names
prejudice dogma tradition science and
more specifically scientists are not
immune my main thesis is that whatever
we whenever we build a model we are
making an interpretation at some point
we will use metaphors to get a handle on
any problem and we need to recognize
this if we were make to make effective
use of our wonderful tools such as both
in language our talent and our time I
like this quote from Eugenia Chang she
may be speaking about pure mathematics
in her quote but I think that the issue
is even more important for applications
it is certainly the case that in all
major projects I have participated
throughout my career it made a
difference for my process control
project the company's management and I
thought that the main problem was to
translate the protocols and procedures
that the lab had established for results
review into algorithms that could be
implemented in code it was only after we
had finished the
project that we discovered that the real
problem was to find a way to analyze the
state of the process in real time and to
effectively communicate that knowledge
to the technologists the first approach
led to the process of quality by
inspection while the latter led to
quality by design Sabina Hassan Felder
quotes paul krugman
the economy he can the economics
profession went astray because
economists as a group mistook beauty
clad in impressive looking mathematics
for truth it is Scioscia is clear that
sociology psychology in to a lesser
extent medicine have the same problem
there are so many examples of poor
papers published by someone armed with a
statistics program and no deep knowledge
of mass that there is a term for pea
hunting whether the problem is that the
wrong kind of mass is being applied to
the problem or that the question is not
well-defined enough to even build a
model this is a question that needs to
be resolved at this stage or the entire
project will be compromised
of course you might think might be able
to find the appropriate tools
mathematical or otherwise to approach a
problem if you're really lucky you will
be able to invent an entirely new branch
of math to tackle a problem as Newton
did with the problem of gravitation ok
it is in this stage translating to mass
that knowledge of hermeneutics will have
the most applicable 'ti to the success
of a project it is here that we prepare
models of the problem that can be solved
using maths in many cases we use we can
use models that already exist in my case
I had to make my own algorithms
fortunately by that time version of
version 1 of Mathematica had been
released and I used it to solve my
problems I suspect for a lot of
applications building your own
algorithms is the rule rather than the
exception when you look at it the right
way a model is
inception Aleve airy similar to a
metaphor it was this connection that
started me on this path a rigorous
treatment of the connections between
model and metaphor is still some years
away however for now it is sufficient to
recognize that both of them are means
for making connections between two
things by analogy it is this similarity
that I use to justify the insights
afforded by hermeneutics for a
mathematical model building I will
illustrate this with an example I used
in building my process control system
having to do with sits and laban zits
zits and laban roughly translates to
setting in life and refers to the
context for a text when it was written
we're in what culture etc in criticism
the text is the data so this term asks a
question where did the data come from
for my project I was dealing with
primarily with numerical data from a
large clinical analyzer so my questions
were where does the data come from other
than the obvious what was going on on
the instrument at the time what were the
connections if any with other data can
the data be trusted if so are there
limits to the types of inferences it can
be made from that data first I had to
invent algorithms to estimate the bias
and imprecision of the instrument in
real time the real citizen laban of the
data previously this information was not
computed second the accuracy of bias
depended on the accuracy of values for
control targets information that was not
in the data set but which needed to be
needed external procedures for
validation when these procedures were
not followed the evaluation made by
process control systems were incorrect
third it was critical to analyze the
results for assays that were
physiologically connected assets and
laban that is essentially orthogonal to
the information provided by controls the
results of this analysis provided
information that was not otherwise
available and because it depended on a
stable human physiology physiology it
produced more trustworthy information
than other types of analysis previous
efforts at quality control in the
clinical lab failed because the
designers of that system made incorrect
assumptions about the process they
assumed that as long as maintenance was
done and there was a long checklist to
ensure that it was the imprecision of an
SI was constant they assumed that
patient results did not need to be
analysed in real-time and it was assumed
that the results were distributed
normally most critically they assumed
that the process was nominally okay and
the QC system was designed solely to
find failure one of the most critical
parts in the design of a model is to be
fully aware of all the assumptions you
are making we've already seen one of the
most critical and most overlooked
assumptions in the previous section or
mathematical methods we proposed to use
to solve problems appropriate for the
question or have we defined the problem
well enough to design algorithms at all
in many cases the most critical bias in
any mathematical endeavor is the
quantification bias in Tricia Wang's
TEDx cambridge talk the human insights
missing from Big Data she says we have
this thing I call quantification bias
which is the unconscious belief of
valuing valuing the measurable over the
in measurable but the problem is that
quantifying is addictive and when we
forget this when we don't have something
to kind of keep that in connect it is
very easy to just throw out data because
it can't be expressed in a numerical
value it is very easy to just slip into
silver bullet thinking as if some simple
solution existed the second notebook
that I have has a whole list of
references for all of these talks and
they're pretty much the the this
particular one is
on YouTube or Ted the good news is that
it's now possible to do mathematics with
objects that are not numbers so just
pictures networks and text it doesn't
matter that these are stored internally
as numbers just as it doesn't really
matter how these things are stored
internally in our brain the mass and
work more from language can treat these
complex things as entities I believe
that this approach will help with the
soft sciences the arts and the
humanities it may even help with physics
the problem with application of math to
these areas in the recent past has been
the drive to quantify everything which
leads to a loss of feel for the data
which in turns leads to questionable
practices the first for most problems
the trick is to take a bunch of data
feed it into the mathematical meat
grinder and get something editable
edible out if you don't know that it's
in laban of the data going in you can't
trust what's coming out for homra no
dekes this is critical but it is also
critical for any problem taken from a
mathematical viewpoint Cathy O'Neill's
book weapons of mass destruction in
James Mickens address cover a lot of the
problem and I referred you to them
they're quite interesting there is a
reason that all the books that I read on
modeling in the 1980s primarily treated
only differential equations as the basis
for a model they were practically the
only tools in the toolbox similarly most
of the statistical tools that were
available practically forced the
assumption the data was normally or log
normally distributed today of course we
have many new tools and our statistical
palette is very large techniques such as
neural nets and agenda kinetic
algorithms hold the promise that more
realistic models can be made even though
these techniques are being used and
misused they're in their infancy
after all differential equations has had
a 300 year Head Start one glaring issue
with machine learning is that they are
treated as black boxes changing what
appears to be minor
parameters can radically affect the
outcome
this phenomena needs to be understood
before using mass for mission-critical
tasks as we understand neural networks
better I am sure that we will be able to
drop some of the assumptions that we are
forced to make resulting in a more
useful result other things may need to
be improved as well for example if we
want to do more than bag of tricks and
now bag of words analysis of text we
will probably need the equivalent of the
oxford english dictionary instead of the
present relatively simple dictionary to
summarize at the foundation of any model
building is a need to understand all the
assumptions that you are making even if
you need to keep the assumptions knowing
that that what they are set what they
are sets limits on what you can do
hermeneutics has been in the business of
examining assumptions for a very long
time and it is a useful tool in addition
knowing what the assumptions are you
might be able to invent new Massa to
eliminate the need for some if not all
the assumptions well from language is a
great tool for inventing new maths
before the middle of the 19th century it
was generally believed that if you prove
something about mathematics you were for
Mises proving something about the real
world the invention of non Euclidean
geometry was the end of this view
although it may be widely believed by
non mathematicians the discovery this
discovery was the main drive behind the
search for rigor that characterized 18th
and 19th and 20th century mathematics it
is pretty clear that Euclid chose his
algorithm so that he could prove
theorems that correspond to facts about
real straight lines circles angles and
so forth the same applies to the axioms
for fields algebra is in other parts of
classical mathematics it was only when
axioms were devised that were consistent
but which did not yield consequences
directly applicable to reality that the
profound separation
between maths and physics for example
was realized this is a good thing
because we are now free to invent new
mathematics it is interesting to us if
there is an application so much the
better of course the point of
computation is that the computation
itself does not add anything that was
not logically implicit in the initial
hypothesis factoring a polynomial for
example does not yield anything that was
not already there although having the
factors may means that you know the
roots of an equation well from language
is essentially a set of rewrite rules so
the construction of the language bring
this point brings this point home
computation therefore it does not add
any pixie dust that magically removes
any biases or assumptions that were
present in the original model or the
data the expression garbage in garbage
out should be on the minds of anyone
using math to solve problems okay you've
got your number 42 what are you going to
do with it as Arthur Dent found out if
you don't really know what the question
is it is difficult to know what the
answer means unless we are very careful
we or especially the people we are doing
the maths for will misinterpret the
results if the original model uses any
data we need not only need to know what
the uncertainties of the data is but we
need to computation does we didn't know
what the computation does with this
uncertainty many types of computation
can give an answer but the uncertainty
is so large that the utility the answer
is essentially zero another problem is
that good results may be taken to mean
that a model may be used to say
something about the world beyond the
context of the computation the poster
boy for this issue is the Ptolemaic
model of the solar system given that the
problem was to predict the positions of
the planets
with an accuracy equal to that of the
measurement error of the time the
Ptolemaic model was a good model it gave
results better results than early
interpretations of the Copernican
hypothesis of course there were several
problems of the old model when bader
data were available better models showed
the error of the old models computations
the main problem of course was that the
model was accepted as Dogma for a
context for which it was not appropriate
over time models such as clerk Maxwell's
mechanistic interpretation of
electrodynamics or the planning Vulcans
did not outlive their usefulness but not
all of these ideas do as Katy Mac has
pointed out it may turn out the quantum
mechanics might just be just tons of
epicycles on top of each other to get
the everything to work out okay what's
all this got to do with Wolfram language
well if the language makes it much
easier to use mathematics to solve
problems than any tool in history before
it I don't know of anyone in my
generation who was involved in science
who did not wish that he or she had
Mathematica in school Wolfram language
is a game changer in the least two broad
areas first Wolfram language is easy
enough to use that people who are not
mathematicians physicists or engineers
might be enticed to use it I grant that
this is not going to be easy given the
way that most K to 12 education has
hidden the beauty of math from 90% of
the population by redefining what math
is just something that is really boring
and then making it difficult to escape
the trap that the students are placed in
however I am optimistic that it will be
possible to interest philosophers and
others in the humanities camp to use
Wolfram language maths has been in both
the CP snows two worlds for most of its
existence and I am certain that many
as exist to make this a reality again
and Stephen Wolfram mentioned this and
his keynote last night when he said that
you know mathematics really is a liberal
art I believe in a lot of other people
believe that we need philosophers to
help build this brave new world simple
computational thinking or mathematical
thinking is only a first step
secondly Wolfram language is the ideal
tool to deal with the issues inherent in
the current music of math particularly
machine learning as more people use
machine learning more people those who
have subject matter expertise not
mathematical knowledge will come to see
the inherent weakness in using a tool
whose inner workings are a black box
people will figure out how to penetrate
this back box at least well enough to
understand the way uncertainty is
handled in any model that uses machine
learning and I think some of the talks
in this conference illustrate this the
primary danger here is that we are so
enamored of our beautiful tools that we
fall victim to what Mickens calls
technological manifest destiny those of
us at this conference may not even
realize its presence much the same way
that fish are not aware of water the key
point is that technology is not neutral
history is littered with the
consequences of forgetting this we can
see the results all over entire fields
of thought are being devalued because
they are being seen as inconsequential
to the STEM fields other fields are
being replaced by changelings that
follow the forms of physics but without
understanding Richard Feynman called it
cargo cult science large numbers of
people rejecting science entirely rather
than being reduced to a number because
there is no connection to their actual
subjective lives Steve Jobs was right
what we need is the marriage of science
and the liberal arts
okay and there's the further reading and
so my rant is done okay and I I really
hope that you look at some of this
further reading the the the Caputo book
in general was what got me off on this
jag I found it in the bookstore in
London and it's really quite quite
interesting
and if any of you wander over into that
section of the bookstore you might find
some other things okay any questions
comments